we appreciate your concern stevenh but
it's not the Scarlet Witch that we fear
from our experience the greatest danger
to the Multiverse it turns out is Doctor
Strange So within phase five and phase
six of the MCU Marvel Studios is going
to start to release some solo movies
about some of the characters who have
been around in the MCU for a pretty long
time now yes a lot of new characters
have made their way into the MCU and we
have a lot more coming but Marvel
Studios is not forgetting about the
characters who exist Ed before Avengers
endgame in fact from what we've heard we
know we're getting a Thor 5 movie and we
know that movie is going to be very very
different than Thor love and thunder
some news that comes as a good surprise
for fans we also heard that we are
getting a solo Scarlet Witch film and
this will sort of tie in and wrap up the
events that happened in W Division and
some events that happened in other
projects as well such as Agatha coven of
chaos I'll do a whole dedicated video on
the Scarlet Witch Project everything we
know and Thor 5 pretty soon but today we
are going to be talking about Doctor
Strange 3 and everything we know about
the movie so far and we actually do know
quite a bit about it and reportedly
Doctor Strange is not going to be
appearing in the next Avengers film
which we are just calling Avengers 5
right now because according to some
reports Avengers King Dynasty is no
longer the title however Kang is still
going to be heavily mentioned in Doctor
Strange 3 and Marvel Studios might even
decide to have him show up at least for
a second or two since they will be
talking about Kang and his threat to the
entire Multiverse in Doctor Strange 3
and Doctor Strange 3 is really when a
lot is going to start to go down and
we're supposedly going to see the true
decay of the Multiverse dying this is
supposed to be the project where they
make it very very clear the Multiverse
is falling apart and if nothing is done
very soon then everyone in every single
universe is going to die which is of
course a topic that was explored in the
last Doctor Strange film Multiverse of
Madness so let's dive into everything we
know and if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest MCU news we're also giving
away a PS5 and Xbox series X more on
that at the end of the video So based
off of everything that we've heard about
Doctor Strange 3 from multiple insiders
the film is going to pick up right where
doctor strange and the Multiverse of
Madness left off in the post credit
scene where Clea shows up Marvel Studios
at that point in time knew what they
wanted to do with the Kang Saga they
knew everything was going to lead up to
Avengers secret War so they knew exactly
what they were doing with this post
credit scene what they were having it
lead into and it seems like the plan was
always for this to directly lead into
Doctor Strange 3 and not another project
that would connect to it somehow Clea
shows up and tells doctor strange that
he caused an incursion and that they're
going to fix it together she then cuts a
slice into reality and they go to the
dark dimension now here is what you need
to know about Clea according to Insider
Alex Perez from the cosmic circus.com
Clea is going to be a member of a group
called The Black priests and in the MCU
the black priests are going to be a
multiversal organization now in Marvel
Comics they were also a multiv veral
group they would go about the Multiverse
trying to stop incursions from happening
trying to stabilize the Multiverse and
they would do this by going about and
destroying each universe's incursion
point and because their measures were so
extreme they were often deemed as
villains however towards the end of the
Multiverse being destroyed Doctor
Strange would join them and he would be
their leader and it looks like Marvel
Studios might have some similar plans
for their story in the MCU with a Twist
it looks like Clea might have Tri
Doctor Strange in that post credit scene
because according to Alex Perez the
black priests are indeed going to go
about the Multiverse trying to stop
incursions from happening however they
believe that incursions are happening
because of doctor strange and all of his
variants and this was kind of pinpointed
and talked about in Multiverse of
Madness where they told doctor strange
that they have realized that the
greatest threat to the Multiverse is do
strange and it looks like the black
priests have decided this as well now as
I mentioned it will be revealed in this
film film that the Multiverse is dying
now of course the black priests are
going to acknowledge that Kang and the
Council of kangs are indeed a problem
and most likely the main danger to the
Multiverse but they will also make it
very clear that doctor strange is also
causing an incursions all across the
Multiverse as well through all of the
different variants of himself so the
black priests are monitoring all of the
different universes in their
headquarters which exists outside of
space and time it exists in the nothing
space of destroy universes so in the
space of two dead universes which were
destroyed because of incursions so to
the black priest Doctor Strange is a
villain to the entire Multiverse but of
course in this film The Black priests
are most likely going to be the villain
to Doctor Strange capturing him and not
allowing him to leave to actually go out
and help the Multiverse from being
destroyed and keep in mind at this point
in time doctor strange doesn't really
know anything about King the Conqueror
he doesn't know anything about the
Council of Kings the black priests are
going to be the first to tell him about
it and most likely show him some of what
Kang and all of his variants have done
but the problem is we know that doctor
strange is not going to be a part of
Avengers 5 and just because Doctor
Strange is kind of being taken off the
map right now doesn't mean that Kang is
going to stop which is why the Avengers
and Avengers 5 are going to lose more
about this story in just a bit but first
big thank you to fume for sponsoring
this video fume is a GameChanger for a
lot of people in turning bad habits into
good habits a lot of people struggle
with these bad habits but fume looks at
these in a different way not everything
in the habit is wrong so instead of a
drastic uncomfortable change why not
just remove the bad from your habit and
that's exactly what fume does they're
Innovative and they're award-winning and
they're a flavored air device that's all
it is it's flavored air so it has none
of the bad things and the bad habit in
it instead of vapor it uses flavored Air
instead of electron RCS fume is
completely natural and instead of
harmful chemicals fume uses delicious
flavors I had actually heard really
great things about fume from my friends
who were struggling with some bad habits
they actually raved about it and how it
helped them which is why I agreed to
partner with them and they sent me some
samples and they honestly are super
refreshing and taste very flavorful and
good and it comes in beautiful real wood
and it's honestly really fun to just sit
there and kind of fidget with if you're
someone who likes to fidget like I do
and I know stop is something we all put
off because it's hard but with fume it's
easy and they have served over 150,000
customers and have thousands of success
stories and that could be you if you
pick up a journey pack today head over
to trf nume.com and use code Cosmic to
save 10% off when you get the journey
pack today that's
trf m.com and use code Cosmic to save an
additional 10% off your order today now
coming from Insider Alex Perez again he
shared on Twitter that doctor strange
would would not be a part of Avengers 5
he then elaborated on this comment by
stating got to give the Avengers a
reason to lose so they can come up in
the next one lol this makes sense that
the Avengers would lose without Doctor
Strange because obviously he is one of
the most powerful people in the main 616
Universe right now probably the only
person who could be stronger than him is
Wanda however Wanda AKA The Scarlet
Witch we know isn't really going to be
an Avengers 5 either we need that solo
Scarlet Witch film to come out so we can
know exactly what happened at the end of
multi of Madness and learn where she
went after because we know she's not
dead so two of the most powerful
characters that the Avengers could have
on their team in Avengers 5 are not
going to be there from what it sounds
like right now the Avengers team in
Avengers 5 will consist of Captain
Marvel Ant-Man and the WASP Hulk
She-Hulk and some others thrown in there
it's also been said Spider-Man will be
in the film however won't really be a
part of the main official Avengers team
so there is one issue with this Avengers
team and that is they really don't have
any magic or really any way to deal with
Kang the Conqueror they are basically
pure Brute Force they are power even
Captain Marvel herself is simply power
and energy they don't have any magic
they don't have any way to deal with
Kang and his future technology his time
travel technology remember in Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantum Mania Kang still
really didn't have everything and we can
assume that he was kind of a lesser
version of Kang and the Council of Kings
were the true villains way Advanced
they've lived a lot longer than him so
their technology is probably a lot
better and clearly they have done some
amazing things the Kang Trio to have
literally thousands hundreds of
thousands maybe infinite amounts of Kang
variants worshiping them and following
them The Avengers the team that I just
listed essentially has no way to disarm
any Kang the Conqueror variant of the
technology that he has Doctor Strange
missing is a major problem for them the
same thing goes for the Scarlet Witch
and it makes sense that they would lose
because they don't have these players
but of course then comes Avengers Secret
Wars and that's where Doctor Strange is
going to play a really big role because
at this point after the events of Doctor
Strange 3 the black priest would have
filled him in on essentially what is
going on in the Multiverse his variants
Doctor Strange variants are going around
causing incursions but also at the same
time King the Conqueror and all of the
Varian of King are going around trying
to essentially control it and make it
their own but also at the same time they
are essentially causing the destruction
of the Multiverse so there are really
kind of two main threats happening in
Doctor Strange 3 one is that Dr strange
and his variants are destroying the
Multiverse and the other is that Kang
and his variants are trying to take over
the Multiverse so between incursions
happening and Kang trying to take over
the Multiverse and Destroy other
universes Doctor Strange has a lot to
worry about when it comes to Avengers
Secret Wars and by the time we get to
Avengers Secret Wars Doctor Strange will
have learned enough from the black
priests about incursions to maybe try to
reverse them however we have all heard
that Marvel Studios is planning to do a
soft reboot and right now we don't
really have any idea of what that looks
like will the Multiverse still exist
most likely however it looks like there
might be fewer universes left over after
Secret Wars and this might be where
Doctor Strange comes into play they may
decide that they can't restore the
entire Multiverse but what they can do
is kind of Infuse two universes together
without them being destroyed or simply
moving people who existed in one
universe that was destroyed into another
one that wasn't but I wouldn't be
surprised if Doctor Strange with the
help of the Scarlet Witch and possibly
Reed Richards and maybe even a good King
variant because you have to imagine that
a good King variant is out there if
literally infinite amounts exist maybe
they all come up with a solution to have
incursions not actually destroy either
of the universes but find a way to save
both of them by fusing them into one
that could be how we get a soft reboot
our universe gets destroyed but maybe
part of it gets infused with another
universe and that's how everything can
essentially start over in the MCU but
it's all going to begin with Doctor
Strange 3 where we really find out how
the Multiverse is dying and how Kang is
taking over so let me know what you
think about these plot details so far do
you like what you hear do you not are
you excited for it let us know in the
comments down below please don't forget
to like the video and if you like the
video and subscribe you're automatically
entered in our giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox series X A PS5 some Marvel
Legends items or some DC items the
winner picks one item and we pick one
winner at the end of each month you can
find us on Instagram and Twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof